oh don't stop okay you can stop
wow I hope this show doesn't suck
it never does happy Friday everyone
you know what we do on Fridays well the
first thing welcome the guests
he's the best thing to happen this
Sunday since church and football host
the Fox News Sunday and author of The
Love Stories of the Bible speak very
arousing the evil Shannon Breen
foreign
it's been less than two months and
Democrats are already wishing they had
voted for him former New York
Congressman Lee Zelda
she considers crawfish to be the sixth
food group co-host of the bottom line on
Fox Business Dagan McDowell
and finally she's never been told you
should come here more often Fox News
contributor captive
before we get to some news stories it's
time for this
[Music]
Greg's leftovers
that's leftovers where I read the jokes
we didn't use this week and as always
it's my first time reading these so
don't blame me if they suck
here we go on Thursday President Biden
had his annual physical and he's in
perfect help for a man his age according
to his team of paleontologists
low hanging fruit
they like those
this week in England that's a country a
letter lost in the mail in 1916 finally
arrived at its intended address in
London more than a century later or as
the U.S postal service calls it ahead of
schedule
Evergreen make fun of the Postal Service
Stanford University researchers have
discovered that the average penis size
has grown 24 over the past three decades
which proves again Stanford's got the
hottest researchers in the business
[Applause]
meanwhile scrotums are apparently
shrinking according to a study from the
College of researchers with cold hands
cover your ears Shannon what would the
women of the Bible think
this is not in the Bible
oh God it gets worse a German ballet
director was fired this week for rubbing
animal feces on the head of a Critic
but he claims it was all a mistake as he
thought she wanted to go out and get
faced
if that's bleeped at home at home that
would rhyme with bit-faced in a recent
interview Chris Cuomo said after getting
canned by CNN he considered killing
himself which is a shame because that
means he finally understood how his
viewers felt
terrible
we wish you well Chris
come on my show bring the Q-tip
California woman who died at a
Cheesecake Factory claims her boyfriend
found a rubber glove and his fried mac
and cheese balls doctors say eating such
a thing could be fatal so the rubber
glove likely saved his life
good joke
a new study suggests men have more
success in online dating if their
profile includes photos of their dog in
it those who have the least success men
with pictures of their wives
the National Institutes of Health claims
to have made a breakthrough towards
creating a male birth control drug which
men could take right before sex to get
full protection researchers haven't
decided what to call it yet but are
leaning toward its street name cocaine
I don't get it
[Laughter]
a man has been arrested and convicted in
England of stealing almost two hundred
thousand Cadbury Cream Eggs and I
believe we have the mug shot
laughs
now to some news so where the hell is
Dawn and Izzy as good as gone another
CNN gas bag is potentially biting the
dust as CNN's arrogant a-hole Don Lemon
wasn't at work today this after coming
under Fire for saying presidential
candidate Nikki Haley is Pastor Prime
because she's 51 years old
yeah me too hashtag
although asking Don when a woman is in
her prime is like asking a vegan how he
likes his filet mignon
[Applause]
mignon is that what I said I don't care
lemon and his co-host were chatting
about Nikki's suggestion that
politicians over the age of 75 should
take mandatory competency tests which
would be a great idea for CNN hosts as
well
then this happened
Nikki Haley is in a prime sorry a woman
is considered being a prime in her 20s
and 30s and maybe 40s I need to qualify
are you talking about Prime for like
child preparing or are you talking about
the facts or Google it
I like that he says sorry right after it
because he knows I'm
but
but that's missing something
Nikki Haley is in a prime sorry when a
woman is considered being her Prime in
her 20s and 30s and maybe 40s
[Music]
but that's only part of it my favorite
quote
talking about the message the facts are
Google it
Google it it seems that's his answer for
everything so Mr Lemon is there any
reason why we should keep you here at
CNN
Google it
since then he was conveniently off this
morning and CNN's chairman put him on
blast on a call with colleagues today
for his part Don tweeted that his
comments were in Artful in Artful
they sure were Rembrandt
fact is the older a woman is the better
she'll have more experience knowing how
to properly iron my shirts
see that's how you do it
lemon you back yourself up with a little
thing called a nexio so whenever you say
something it comes up and undercuts it
Shannon you're an expert on um women
especially women in the Bible what do
you think of Don lemon's comments well
apparently passed by Prime so I don't
know that I can comment on these things
um I had a transition plan I was gonna
like
like next and then full Assisted Living
care but I think that I'm just gonna
skip that stuff and apparently just get
my Walker and head straight down to the
nursing home based on what he had to say
okay
obviously his error was uh bringing up a
reproduction when we're talking about
cognitive function but he thought he was
being clever he was stupid but unlike
you like he's trying to apologize you
will not apologize for your sexist
comments you're just going to own them
because I'm not a sexist
that's a sexist would say that's not
mexio to run again the nexio is guilty
as charged yep I'm gonna skip you Lee
and go to the other women first because
that would be sexist if I asked your
opinion
so here's my theory Degen why was lemon
so arrogant about everything he's gay
he's black he's a liberal and that made
him think he was impenetrable so he flew
too close to the woke son
he was playing woker poker
and he lost to a woman
how's that I have never ever wanted to
work at CNN until now
just give me 24 hours with John Lemon
because I am over the hill and through
the woods and I've walked through the
valley of the shadow of death
and I fear no evil
but because
because of my age uh I have learned how
to drive a man in very a very short
period of time into a blind rage and
into a psych ward
Without Really Ever uttering a word yeah
he'd quit a day I um
I still think I find him entertaining a
cat but I love his defense did you hear
his defense some of his best friends are
women
he said that and then he mentioned a
couple of women Dana Bash and somebody
else and I imagine if somebody said to
Don Lemon oh yeah some of my best
friends are gay or some of my best
friends are black he would say that's
exactly what a bigot would say so he's
basically he's using a sexist argument
some of my best friends are women so I
can be sexist what say you yeah I love
how he was so confident saying Google it
you know it's not me I don't think that
it's not me saying that Google it when
really no one else has ever said that
women have an exactly 15-year window
between 35 and 50 before they're allowed
to be president yeah uh as you mentioned
he must have been referring to the like
stigma of female aging when it comes to
uh you know sexual desirability which is
I know a lot of hot women in their 50s
um but even if like that's what he's
referring to what was he saying with
that that like you need to have Society
at large want to bang you if you can
want to be president I think I do not I
do not think people feel that way about
Joe Biden
although there are a few perverts in
accounting that would take a step out
perverts Lee you're a man
some would say a good man a fair man an
honest man what uh What uh do you glean
from this situation I mean he's not
going to say anything about Kamala
Harris hasn't I think she's 58 yes
didn't say anything about Hillary
Clinton good point and I mean clearly
he's being a partisan he is daring CNN
to fire him he's double dare he's triple
daring and if you don't take a stand
over at CNN you have other people who
are like Don Lemon over there who are
going to keep pressing further daring
those in charge to actually show any
amount of Standards uh he is a lemon he
should be given back I I would say uh
with with regards to Don Lemon at this
particular point in time you know he's
talking about who's past their Prime
who's in their prime it reminds me of
the opening scene of a Major League
where they're all sitting around with
the roster of the team that they're
trying to put together to finish that
last and the one guy points out most of
these players never even had a prime you
notice that you know CNN is stacking up
their roster Don Lemon at the top he's
like the captain of a team who's like
Don Lemon never even had a prime no he
didn't he would say and the best part
about this so think about this as an
idea for Fox right this show does a
special because glennon's going to be
gone in a month we get lemon
Chris Cuomo Brian stelter look at cat
and Tyrus over here you get to get to
sit together but with the special CNN
reunion
and we do it it's like it's like a Very
Brady reunion remember that
by the way you know he's got to be happy
as Chris Cuomo because Don Lemon stabbed
him in the back when Cuomo got fired
right didn't he say something like why
are we paying him if he doesn't because
he got left with Severance why should we
be paying him so that so Cuomo must be
smiling ear to ear uh
that was weird that I did that with my
fingers
a little update before we go up George
Santos the congressman agreed to do the
show on Twitter but on one condition and
of course he won't tell you what it is
what a freak
it's like as long as he doesn't tell me
the condition he can't be on the show
I'd love to do your show but on one
condition what is it I'm not telling you
we're not going to dinner George if
that's what you think
maybe I'll go to dinner with us yeah
well if you're going then I'm going okay
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else